hi there steve kaufman here and today
i'm going to again talk about language
learning and if you like talking about
language learning please subscribe to my
channel
today i want to talk about
fitness and language learning and
particularly crossfit and language
learning now
we need to be fit in order to
engage in physical activity the more fit
we are normally the better we do in
sports for example in skiing or tennis
or whatever it might be and i think the
same is true in language learning uh we
need to make ourselves develop our our
stamina and our physical ability to
learn languages and this is something i
talked about in my japanese video and i
will get it be getting back to in that
japanese video
and in particular i want to talk about
crossfit because i started doing
crossfit here in vancouver ah a couple
of weeks ago and crossfit focuses on a
limited number of exercises they work
the legs the core and the shoulders but
always is sort of in a free-standing
situation you're doing squats you're
doing
jerks or snatches
and while it's controversial
their view is that this is very good
because you're not just focusing on one
muscle whereas if you're sitting at a
machine and i'm in a gym you might just
be working on your biceps or something
i have found it excellent i find that it
has improved my posture i feel very good
so
the question is is there sort of us a
limited number of exercises
that we can do in language learning that
you know by focusing on these we
increase our fitness fitness for
language learning now
remember that
uh whatever we whatever this sort of
concentrated exercise might be we still
have to do a number of other things
however
if we can increase our alertness our
ability to notice i think the ability to
notice is is like fitness in sports the
more things you notice the better you're
going to learn the language so what i've
been doing in the last week or so
uh is that i'll read my text in polish
and i'll focus on underlining and
highlighting more phrases and then i can
hear the text to speech
of those phrases so i kind of hear them
sounding in my mind often these are
phrases with verbs in them i think those
are the most important kinds of phrases
and then i go to the dictation section
at link and i hear the text to speech
and then i have to type in what i heard
dictation so i'm listening to two three
four five words of polish i have to
write in what i heard wow it's amazing
how i mishear how you assume you're
hearing something in fact what the
person said was quite different and so
training myself to hear better what is
said and to write correctly
uh is not only enabling me to remember
these phrases but is also increasing my
alertness my ability to notice therefore
my fitness so i think this
principle of crossfit like a limited
number of exercises that are very good
for you
it's not the only thing you do but they
really improve your general fitness i
think the same might be true of this
emphasis on phrases and then doing
dictation so but i'll continue doing
this and i'll report back to you but i
look forward to hearing your comments
thank you for listening bye for now
you